dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly July fair in this
piece of work we seek to control digital
characters in real-time it happens the
following way we specify a target
trajectory and the algorithm has to
synthesize a series of motions that
follows that path to make these motions
as realistic as possible
this is typically accomplished by
unleashing a learning algorithm on a
large database that contains a ton of
motion information previous techniques
did not have a good understanding of
these databases and they often
synthesize motions from pieces that
correspond it to different kinds of
movements this lack of understanding
results in stiff and natural output
motion intuitively it is a bit like
putting together a sentence from a set
of letters that were cut out one by one
from different newspaper articles it is
a fully formed sentence but it lacks the
smoothness and the flow of a properly
aligned piece of text this is a neural
network based technique that introduces
a phase function to the learning process
this phase function augments the
learning with the timing information of
a given motion with this phase function
the neural network recognizes that we
are not only learning periodic motions
but it knows when these motions start
and when they end the final technique
takes very little memory runs in real
time and it accomplishes smooth walking
running jumping and climbing motions and
so much more over a variety of terrains
with flying colors in a previous episode
we have discussed a different technique
that accomplished something similar with
a low and high level controller one of
the major selling points of this
technique is that this one offers a
unified solution for terrain traversal
with using only one neural network this
have the potential to make it really big
on computer games and real time
animation it is absolutely amazing to
witness this and be a part of the future
make sure to have a look at the paper
which also contains the details of the
terrain feeding step to make this
learning algorithm capable of taking
into consideration a variety of
course I would also like to thank lawdy
oppa machi for his amazing work in
translating so many of these episodes to
Italian this makes two minute papers
accessible for more people around the
globe and the more people we can reach
the happier I am thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]